Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
"Orden, orden.
¿A quién tenemos aquí?"
"Su Señoría, esta es Cleopatra,
La reina egipcia que
con sus asuntos espeluznantes
destruyó a dos de los mejores
generales de Roma
y eso tuvo como consecuencia
el fin de la República".
"Su Señoría, esta es Cleopatra,
una de las mujeres
más poderosas de la historia
cuyo reinado llevó a Egipto a casi
22 años de estabilidad y prosperidad".
"Uh, ¿por qué ni siquiera
conocemos su aspecto?"
"En su mayoría el arte y las descripciones
vinieron mucho después de su vida
en el siglo I a.C.,
como la gran parte de
lo escrito sobre ella".
"Entonces, ¿qué sabemos realmente?
Cleopatra VII fue la última representante
de la dinastía ptolemaica,
una familia griega macedonia
que gobernó Egipto
tras la conquista de Alejandro Magno.
Gobernó conjuntamente en Alejandría
con su hermano,
-con quien también estaba casada,
hasta que éste la exiló".
"Pero, ¿qué tiene todo esto
que ver con Roma?"
"Egipto había sido durante mucho tiempo
un Estado cliente de Roma,
y el padre de Cleopatra incurrió
en grandes deudas con la República.
Tras ser derrotado por Julio César
en la guerra civil de Roma,
el general Pompeyo buscó refugio en Egipto
pero fue ejecutado
por el hermano de Cleopatra".
"Eso le habrá gustado A César".
"En realidad, lo halló indecoroso
y exigió el reembolso de la deuda egipcia.
Podría haber anexado Egipto,
pero Cleopatra lo convenció de que
en cambio la reinstaurara en el trono".
"Se dice que era bastante convincente".
"¿Y por qué no? Cleopatra
era una mujer fascinante.
Comandó ejércitos a los 21 años,
hablaba varios idiomas,
y se educó en una ciudad
con la mejor biblioteca del mundo
y algunos de los eruditos
más grandes de la época".
"Mmm".
"Mantuvo a César como holgazán en Egipto
durante meses cuando Roma lo necesitaba".
"César hizo más que holgazanear.
Estaba fascinado por la cultura
y el conocimiento egipcios,
y aprendió mucho durante su tiempo allí.
Cuando regresó a Roma,
reformó el calendario,
encargó un censo,
hizo planes para una biblioteca pública,
Y propuso muchos nuevos proyectos
de infraestructura".
"Sí, muy ambiciosos, exactamente
lo que lo llevó a la muerte".
"No culpe a la reina
por la extraña política romana.
Su trabajo era gobernar Egipto,
y lo hizo bien.
Estabilizó la economía,
manejó la vasta burocracia,
y detuvo la corrupción de
sacerdotes y funcionarios.
Cuando la sequía asoló,
abrió los graneros al público
y aprobó una amnistía fiscal,
mientras preservó en el reino
su estabilidad e independencia
sin revueltas durante
el resto de su reinado".
"Entonces, ¿qué salió mal?"
"Tras la muerte de César,
esta reina extranjera
no pudo dejar de entrometerse
en asuntos romanos".
"En realidad, facciones romanas
demandaron su ayuda.
Y, por supuesto, no tuvo más opción
que apoyar a Octavio y Marco Antonio
para vengar a César, aunque solo fuere
por el bien de su hijo".
"Y otra vez, ella proporcionó
su apoyo 'particular' a Marco Antonio".
"¿Qué importancia tiene eso?
¿Por qué a nadie parece importarle
los incontables asuntos adicionales
de César o Antonio?
¿Por qué suponemos que
se interpuso en las relaciones?
Y por qué solo se define a las
mujeres poderosas por su sexualidad?"
"Orden".
"Cleopatra y Antonio fueron un desastre.
Ofendieron a la República
con sus ridículas celebraciones
sentados en tronos de oro
vestidos como dioses
hasta que Octavio convenció
a toda Roma de su megalomanía".
"Y sin embargo Octavio
fue quien atacó a Antonio,
anexó Egipto,
y se autoproclamó emperador.
Fue el temor romano al poder de una mujer
lo que puso fin a su República,
no la mujer en sí".
"Qué irónico".
La historia de Cleopatra
sobrevivió principalmente
en los relatos de sus enemigos en Roma,
y luego los escritores llenaron
las lagunas con rumores y estereotipos.
Tal vez nunca sepamos toda la verdad
sobre su vida y su reinado,
pero podemos separar hechos de rumores
poniendo la historia a prueba.